The Joe Rogan Experience they're
historically you know California has
been the world leader in Cults for a
very long time and I would say that has
not stopped and and that continues did
you know that the building that I bought
for my comedy club initially was owned
by a cult fantastic it was owned by a
cult from West Hollywood called the
Buddha field that migrated out to uh
Austin when they were being investigated
by the occult awareness Network you got
it fantastic yeah are they gone are they
still there no they're gone there's a
great documentary on it called holy hell
I used to watch it it's pretty Bonkers
but they're from California from
California you know people the people's
Temple you know part of this is a great
story of San Francisco is the people's
Temple which became famous for the Jim
Jones that where he killed everybody
killed everybody with poison Kool-Aid in
the jungles and Guyana uh he he that
that was a San Francisco cult for like a
decade right before they went to the
jungle and everybody talks about the
jungle nobody talks about the San
Francisco part so are there a bunch that
are running right now that are
successful big time yeah totally really
oh yeah totally yeah you know it's
called all over the place I know a bunch
of them yeah wow yeah yeah and how would
they run well some of them are older
there's two sort of groupings there's
the sort of 60s Cults that are still
kind of running
uh there's what is it there's one called
the family in like Southern California
that's still going from the 60s
um there's uh there's a bunch of them
you know running around you know there's
there's you know there was there was a
big cult for a long time sort of cultish
kind of thing around what was it um not
Erawan but it was
um you know so they're still like that
that whole orbit uh that's the
Psychedelic groups all that stuff yeah
that's from the 60s and then there were
a bunch of sort of tech Cults in the 80s
and 90s with names like the extropeans
um and um you know there were a bunch of
these guys and then
um more recently there's a lot of this
you'll hear these terms like rationalist
post-rationalist uh effective altruism
yes existential risk
um long-termism they sometimes say
um and what you find is the people again
the people associated with these tend to
be very smart uh they tend to be very
prolific they tend to do a lot many of
them are involved in in Tech and then
they end up with let's say alternative
living arrangements alternative food and
sex configurations
um and you know lots of group oriented
you know and it's like what's the line
right what's what's the line between
basically a what's the line between a
social group that all lives together
that all has sex together that all eats
the same foods that is not a cult that
you know engages in lots of you know at
some point they start to form you know
belief systems that are not you know
compatible with the outside world and
they start to kind of go on their own
orbit do they generally have a leader
um so I mean there are generally leaders
I mean there is a pattern I think he
talks about it in in the book chaos I
mean there typically is a pattern it's
typically it's typically a guy
um you know there's typically a there's
there's a there's a male female Dynamic
right that plays out inside these things
that you kind of see over and over again
um and so they often they often end up
with more women than men
um you know for for
mysterious reasons but
um yeah and then yeah there's there's
usually some kind of leader although you
know the other thing is happening now is
you know a lot of modern Cults you know
they're kind of quasi-cults there's like
there'll be a physical component but
there's also an internet component now
right and so the the ideas will spread
online right so there'll kind of be
members of the call or quasi members of
The Cult or quasi members of the
quasi-cult that'll be you know online
and maybe at some point they actually
come and physically join up
um yeah so and by the way let me say
like generally I'm Pro cult
like I'm actually quite Pro cult
um well the reason it's the same reason
I pro-fringe right which is like you're
gonna have P if you're gonna have people
who are going to be thinking new things
they're going to tend to be these kinds
of people they're going to be people who
are in the French they're going to come
together in groups when they come
together in groups they're they're going
to exhibit called like characteristics
what you're saying resonates everything
you're saying makes sense but how did
you get to these conclusions like like
it seems that like accepting Fringe and
exciting like accepting the chaos of San
Francisco like this is good this is a
part of it this is how this works this
is why it works like how did you develop
that perspective well it's just if you
take a historical perspective it's just
like okay I mean it's like an easy
example if you like rock music it just
basically came modern rock and roll
basically came from the hate Ashbury in
the basically mid to late 60s and then
from Laurel Canyon which was another one
of these sort of cultish environments in
the middle late 60s and there was like
specific moments in time in both of
these places and you know basically all
of the great rock and roll from that era
that determine everything that followed
basically came out so you know do you
want that or not right right if you want
on it you know that's what you get
um I'll give you here's the crazy here's
a crazy um it's the um uh there's the
other book about Laurel Canon that's
even crazier than chaos it's the book
called uh weird scenes in the canyon oh
okay you would love this one so so
Laurel Canyon was like the hate Ashbury
of Los Angeles right so Laurel Canyon
was like the music scene the sort of
music and drug and hippie scene of the
it's Laurel County is actually where the
hippie movement started um there was
actually a specific group in Laurel
Canyon in LA in about 1965.
um there's a guy named Vito pelicus
um and uh and he had a group called The
Freaks and they were like uh they were
like a non-violent version of the Manson
cult
um and it was all these young girls and
and they basically would go to clubs and
they had they were the ones to do the
beads and the hair and like all the
leather and like all the all the hippie
stuff like they got they got that
rolling
um and so like they were they were in
location and then Laurel Canyon it was
like Ground Zero there was like this
moment where it's like Jim Morrison the
doors and Crosby Stills and Nash and
Frank Zappa and it was it John Phillips
um and um was The Mamas the Papas and
the birds and the monkeys and like all
of these like iconic bands of that time
basically catalyzed over about a
two-year period in little canyon
um the the conspiracy the conspiracy
theory in this book basically is that
the whole thing was an op and the the
the the military intelligence op
um and the the evidence for the theory
is that there was an air force uh uh
military propaganda production facility
at the head of Laurel Canyon called
Lookout Mountain uh which uh right which
today Jared Leto owns and actually yeah
so I'm just gonna say that yeah but it's
it was a in in that era in the 50s
through the 70s it was a vertically
integrated uh military yes uh it was a
production facility uh for film and
music
um but by the way if you met Jared Leto
uh briefly yeah one of the most
interesting guys I've ever talked
incredible and it makes total sense
totally normal like really fun to talk
to not like what you would think of as a
famous actor at all I had dinner with
him and drinks he's [__] great guy
but he lives in a military boat he
showed me all the pictures he showed me
I'm like this is wild yeah so it's
amazing if you believe the moon landing
was fake this is where they affected
like this this is I thought they'd
supposed to do it in the Nevada desert
no these are the sounds because they had
sound stations that totally contained
sound stages they had full sound
production capability
um and so the theory goes basically that
so there were three parts to the
conspiracy theory so one is they have
the production facility right there
right where all these musicians showed
up two is the musician's like a very
large percentage of these young
musicians um were uh Sons and Daughters
of senior U.S military and intelligence
including Morrison including Jim
Morrison whose father was the head of
Naval operations for the Vietnam War at
the time
um and there were these other forget
which ones but there were these other
musicians at the time where their
parents were like senior and like
military like psychological operations
and like that's that's all real like
that's all documented and then third is
the head of the Rand Corporation who was
one of The Inspirations for the Dr
Strangelove character in the movie
um so he was the guy doing all the
nuclear plant planning for nuclear war
he lived right in the heart of the
hippies uh in Laurel Canyon in this in
this famous house that's that's still
there and so the theory basically goes
that the anti-war movement before the
hippies was basically a square movement
it was all these basically young people
very clean cut the men were all wearing
if you look at old like Vietnam War
protests like everybody's all like
dressed up like they're going to
business meeting it was like it was
developing into a real threat and so the
theory is the hippie movement and rock
and roll and the drug culture of the 60s
was developed uh in order to basically
sabotage the anti-war movement wow right
uh and which which basically is what
happened right because then what
happened is the anti-war boom it became
associated with hippies and that caused
Americans to right decide what side they
were on and then that led to Nixon being
elected twice which was also a part of
chaos because that was the idea behind
the Manson family and funneling acid to
them the facility was equipped with a
Sound Stage screening rooms film storage
vaults and naturally a bomb shelter
during its 22 years of operation Lookout
Mountain laboratory produced
approximately 6500 classified films for
the Department of Defense and the atomic
energy commission documenting nuclear
test series such as operation Greenhouse
operation teapot and operation Buster
jangle so one of the conspiracy theories
okay here's another conspiracy theory
the you've seen all the you've seen all
the granny footage of nuclear test
blasts that if you're sure the mushroom
clouds and they're always these grainy
things and there's all these like little
houses lined up in these little trees
lined up and it blows everything down
well it's always been a conspiracy
theory that those were all basically
fabricated at this facility that those
bombs actually were never detonated
um and basically the US military was uh
was basically faking these bomb tests to
freak out the Russians to make us think
that we had
um uh weapons we had basically a potent
potency to our nuclear weapon Arsenal
that we actually didn't have at the time
how did they fake it um they just did
yeah exactly this is it well so there's
a um yeah okay so here's the question
right so what happened okay so this is
great okay you'll love this so what
happened to the camera
you son of a [__]
you son of a [__] how is that happening
if the camera is like totally stable and
fine oh my God and by the way in the
film is fine the radio the the radiation
that didn't cause any damage to the film
oh my God this looks like well by the
way okay we'll do this we'll do a little
one more time here where's the closest
of the car behind the house it just
showed up oh okay wait a minute first it
wasn't there no comes from no car second
is it really look like a car does that
look like a real car that's insane and
look at the um yeah and look at the when
the house blows look at the uh the wood
does that look like it's those are
full-size like you know giant Lumber
beams
as they go flying
yeah
is that a house or is that like you know
a you know is that a 12 foot you know 12
inch uh you know scale model what right
so like the [__] car anyway I don't
know like I have no idea having said
that if that was fake it was faked at
Lookout Mountain
right at the exact same place and time
well did they have the kind of special
effects to do something like that in the
40s well so the the conspiracy the full
conspiracy theories it was uh Stanley
Kubrick
which again I I I I have no idea well
that does look fake there's also the
camera didn't move it all year you know
what it looks like go back to that real
quick
it looks like the smoke is too big watch
watch when it hits
like it's the volume like the size of it
it looks small I mean you know what I'm
saying I mean it looks like something
we're looking at something that's like a
few inches tall so if you watch Like
Making of Star Wars any of the you know
any movies before CGI whenever they do
anything like that it's always with
these tiny models yes and they just
basically that's what they do is they
slow it down and then they add sound
yeah this looks fake as [__] right the
the the clouds just don't look realistic
right like it looks like they're too big
and they move too quickly back and forth
let's get another one it's like okay
what the camera camera's fine
that's hilarious here we go
okay they're moving the camera gun okay
but even though but even even still the
camera got knocked over right now what
is then not destroyed is there a death
uh like some sort of a response to that
have they come with some sort of an
explanation not that I know of that
seems so fake yeah yeah wow who can tell
does that make you wonder about other
things well I mean it's like in our time
right it's like how much stuff do you
read in the news where you're like okay
I know that's not true right and then
you're like okay everything I read in
the history books like I was told it was
true it's like yeah it was definitely
that that one though is really weirdly
compelling there's another video of them
setting up these houses which I mean I
guess you could make after the fact and
say yeah this is fake but this is here
them setting it up yeah you just do
real-size houses
huh I don't know I don't know I I I
assume this is all I assume this is all
not true but it is fun to think about
why would you assume it's not true the
camera alone like this alone like yeah
where is the phone where's that camera
camera because they have to have an
explanation someone must have asked them
at some point or nobody asked maybe yeah
it might be one of those wow look what
they did
we know the Soviets did it too Yuri
Gagarin when he was in that uh capsule
in space you you can clear if you see
the actual capsule and then you see the
film footage that was supposedly of him
in the capsule there's like two
different sources of light there's
Shadows the camera somehow or another is
in front of them this big ass camera
there's no room in the thing like they
filmed it afterwards and it looks fake
like oh I'm sure he really did go into
space but that wasn't it
that was some weird propaganda
Gary Kasparov has the theory you know
this is the theory they're missing
centuries
what yeah yeah Castro has the theory
that there are centuries that didn't
happen what do you mean which is it just
literally centuries that like this whole
idea the Middle Ages lasted 1200 years
or whatever is just like not true really
yeah why does he think that uh there's
there's something about the you know
whatever is there like enough historical
evidence to support it and you know
various people over you know various
authorities over time who wanted to tell
various stories about how long you know
regimes had been in place or whatever oh
so he thinks it's exaggerated yeah yeah
basically not not as much time has
passed as we think well that's quite
possible yeah how would we know